Because if like if you are one of those
crazy rock climber dudes like Alex
Honnold and he's crazy. He's crazy. I love
him though. He's told, have you talked?
Have you met him? Yeah, I've had him
on a couple of times. Oh my God. Yeah,
he's awesome. I'm sure he is. Of
course it's a big deal as fucked up.
You know this right when he has no fear.
No, he does have fear. You're wrong.
Oh really? Absolutely. As fear.
He just understands his capacity and
his ability you think is he says,
I can do this,
therefore I should not be afraid cause
I read that he takes scanned his brain
and that his, his fear
centers are different than
the rest of us is what I read.
Maybe that's wrong.
I don't know.
Did he tell you he didn't say anything
about that? I think he's just,
I don't know about that man.
He said basically that the experience,
he just stays mellow and calm and then
if things go wrong, it's really bad.
Like you don't want to be freaking out.
Yes. It's still, he doesn't divers.
You don't panic when you're underwater.
And you lose your way. Right.
There was a consumes oxygen.
A lot of amazing story that
my friend Donald Cerrone,
he's a UFC fighter told about
being trapped in a cave in, in,
in this bigger watering out when
it was running out of oxygen. Yeah.
Horrible, crazy, scary story. And you have
those guys are also different. These are,
they either they're born that
way or they learn to be that way.
You have to keep calm because when
you and I lose our cool and start
hyperventilating, our auction
consumption skyrockets. Right.
And that's the opposite of what
you need to do in that situation.
It's actually what he talked about,
you know,
like trying to stay calm and
battling the demons. Yeah.
Not going to die like this. Yes.
Yeah. What an incredible story. Yeah.
The Alex Honnold thing, I or something, I
watched the movie, what it talks to them.
He got an MRI and they said that he was
quote, what did it say? Yeah, he's a,
Migdal is different, but what
did it say? How does it say it?
The kids Amygdala isn't firing. Yes. Okay.
But isn't that possible that that's
just through development of constant,
it is also possible calm while you're in
life threatening situations as possible.
And they would like to see fighters
brains measured in that regard.
I would like to see soldiers, special
forces guys. Yes, I think that's right.
And the guy's a special force guys.
It's like the capacity to shoot back when
you're being shot at keeping your calm
moving positions, you know, and so forth.
Those are all very important to
abilities, not panicking. Uh,
but and it is also the case
that some people, for example,
the most famous study in this regard
was a study of London taxi drivers.
London taxi drivers can go from any point
in the city to any other point in the
city.
It's called the knowledge.
They have a mental map of the
whole city and it's freakish.
It takes years to be able to know how to
navigate the city with the thousands of
Nate,
tens of thousands of street names.
And they can do it by like dead reckoning.
They a scan.
This was a paper about 10 years ago.
They brain scan these guys and they had,
I forgot what region of the brain,
but they had through learning it is
felt modify that region of the brain.
So it's possible.
Holland is like you say that he learned
to be this way that does it make dull
isn't firing because he trained himself
but I Honolulu, Honolulu huddled,
I'm sorry Hahnel does this way because
he learns to me but it's more likely I
think that he's like Usain bolt
that was born with incredibly a high
preponderance of fast twitch fibers in
his leg so he can run like the wind and
he trains as well. You have both, right?
Good athletes require both innate ability
plus training. Yes, and I think uh,
handled is probably like that.
He was probably born with an Amygdala,
doesn't fire so much and
he's an amazing climber.
It's purely speculative,
right? Like the end. They also,
the nature versus nurture would
apply to chess players as well.
I would like to see their brains can
like Gary Casbar off. I know Gary. Yes.
I would love to see that. I got brain
scan. Yes. Yeah. He's an interesting guy.
What I'll say.
The article goes way more into depth
and Nyquil I just showed you about just
that sentence. She, she's at
the doctor who studied them.
It was specifically looks at people that
go under high stress and look for those
kinds of things. She's been doing that
since 2005 I guess, and she goes, it's,
it's pages long. This whole thing
about his brain, but it is unusual,
but it also, the amount of time, think
about people that are in high stress.
High stress is one thing.
This kid is in a life threatening
absolute fatality situation.
Mistake his death every
day. I know all day. I know.
I mean, he lives in a van and just
climbs. Yes. That's what he does.
It's really fast. Yes it is.
It is. It's amazing. Honestly.
It's amazing. So I mean,
I don't know. I'd never met him. I
admire him very much. And I love this.
Like we said at the beginning,
it's very important to have skills.